-Guys, finally it is Tuesday.
It's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all
going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have your voting
clickers at your seats.
You can all vote -- Yeah.
That's probably yours, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
I just want you to have fun.
We're going to see
the results live.
Tariq, Roots?
Tariq, you have your clicker?
-Yeah, I'm done already,
thanks.
-No, no,
we didn't even start --
We didn't even start
the game yet.
-Wait, what?
-We didn't start the game yet.
Don't vote on Tariq's --
-Can you unvote?
-No, you can't
unvote either, no.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes,
we will tweet it out live on
the show on a commercial break
so you can all like it
and "wetweet" it.
[ Audience ahs ]
Yeah, it's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers ]
Our first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't like that one.
-You didn't like it?
-Nope.
-I think it's alright.
I mean, I kind of get it.
-I dig it.
-You dig it?
Alright. The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
Ooh. Wow.
[ Sad tuba ]
Very honest audience.
They did not enjoy that one.
[ Laughter ]
They did not like that one.
It's okay.
We have a couple more.
Here we go.
-We're warming up.
-Yeah, we're warming up.
This next one is...
-Thinker.
-I can tell by people's eyes
that they're saying, "No."
[ Laughter ]
They're masked.
And they're just looking
at me like --
[ Laughter ]
I can tell they pressed no.
I'm going to say this one is --
What was the last one,
how many no's?
76 likes?
So I'm going to say
this one is probably
in the 150 range of "no."
[ Laughter ]
-Ah.
-This might be one of
the worst ones ever.
Let's see the results.
[ Sad tuba ]
Yeah. Very close. I felt it.
I knew it.
I could tell.
They looked at me like,
"No, Jimmy, not going to do it.
I'm going to let you drown a
little bit, then I'll save you."
I go, "Alright,
teach me a lesson."
How about this next one here?
-Yes, you do.
You know you do.
-I do, but is that more fact
than it is funny?
-It's a fun fact.
-I always start
at chapter four.
-What?
-I don't want to hear
about their childhood,
and when they discovered music.
-I don't want
to hear about that either.
"My mom was born --"
I go, "Hey, if I want to read
about your mom,
I would get her biography."
[ Laughter ]
I think we're riding
this train together.
And I think that we're 50/50
on this.
I think we're split down
the middle, if I'm being nice.
Let's see the results.
What?
I feel like I don't know
you anymore.
What happened to us?
We had something.
-Wait, you didn't want them
to like that?
-No, I like that they liked it.
I just didn't expect them
to like it.
I liked it.
I mean, we both did
the same thing.
I just thought the numbers
would be more even.
This one's pretty good.
What do you think about this one
before I say it?
-Hated it.
[ Laughter ]
-Next up...
-I always say that.
-Oh.
Why not, man?
I don't know if I'm happy,
but just do it,
and you probably end up happy.
I think this one's up there.
-This is the winner.
-The winner? The last one was
pretty good too.
I think this one is going
to be the winner.
Let's see the results
on this one right here.
Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a good one.
But this last one
is pretty good, too.
But that one's going to be
the winner, I think.
But this last one's good.
Check this one out.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it kind of
just goes in the floor.
The floor eats it.
-You find it months later.
-You find it years later.
Dried.
"Honey, did you drop this bead?"
-Right.
-Yeah, I liked that one but I
don't know if it's gonna be --
What was the last record?
-184.
It's got to beat 184.
It's gotta be a good one.
I don't know
if it's going to happen.
Let's see the results.
No. It did not win!
[ Dinging ]
It was high, but did not win.
The winner was
tweet number four.
[ Dinging ]
You should still clap
your hands just in case.
I will post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a wetweet.
Why not? Enjoy.